[Music]
hi I'm Scott a snowy and I'm Angie Rito
and we are the chef owners of Don äôt
restaurant in the West Village we're
both really passionate about
italian-american food and we basically
put our own twist on classic Italian
dishes such as lasagna instead of doing
a traditional layer of lasagna we do
basically like pinwheels Angie was
looking at a picture on Instagram of
like cinnamon buns or something a light
bulb went off in her head and she was
like oh it'd be cool if we can make
lasagna like in that form and it ended
up being a really smart idea and also
growing up we would eat lasagna
everybody always wants like the crispy
ends which is usually typically only the
four corners but when you cook it like
this the entire top gets really crispy
it's like the perfect balance everybody
gets like a crispy part and then the
soft part and it's much lighter because
it's not compacted like a traditional
[Music]
the way we make the lasagna here is we
take fresh pasta sheets that we make
in-house we cook them briefly in boiling
salted water cooled them down then we
spread a layer of bechamel ax on top on
top of that we add a layer of Parmesan
cheese a good amount of mozzarella
cheese we had a second layer of pasta on
top of that we put a generous helping of
our bolognese sauce which sort of like a
typical Bolognese but we add a couple of
unique ingredients to it we had Italian
sausage pancetta
we had some Rosano tomatoes after we
spread the layer of Bolognese we add a
small layer of bechamel at the top to
sort of seal the roll closed once we
roll it up and at that point you roll it
seal it closed
cool it down and then we slice it into
pinwheels and we place the pinwheels in
a casserole dish with San Marzano tomato
sauce some dollops of fresh robiola
cheese we decided to use robiola cheese
instead of ricotta cheese which is
typically used in
lasagnas because it has a tankiness to
it and it's also it has a very light
texture so it makes it though the dish
overall come off as a lot lighter we put
it in a 400 degree oven for about 12 to
15 minutes when we take it out of the
oven we finish it with olive oil and
fresh chopped parsley and that's the
process our style of food is a new take
on Italian American food like a modern
Italian American restaurant I feel like
especially in New York City you know the
markets a little bit saturated with
Italian American restaurants so we
wanted to do something unique and
different there are a couple sort of
iconic restaurants in New York you know
Don Antonio Don Peppe and it's always a
man's name so this is sort of like you
know it's supposed to be a little bit
cheeky but it's like I'm the matriarch
good god we're both really passionate
about what we do and we both I don't
think can see ourselves doing anything
else and this allows us to do it
together
[Music]